im dezember 2015 unterschrieben in paris
insgesamt 195 länder ein abkommen das es
so noch nie gegeben hat
ziel dieses abkommens ist es die
erwärmung der erde im vergleich zum
vorindustriellen zeitalter auf unter
zwei grad zu beschränken
durch das pariser klima abkommen soll
verhindert werden dass unsere erde und
nachfolgende generationen den
schwerwiegenden gefahren des
klimawandels ausgesetzt werden wie
wichtig so ein abkommen ist zeigen die
forschungsergebnisse der letzten jahre
fast alle wissenschaftler sind sich
einig die zeit drängt denn die folgen
des menschengemachten klimawandels
können dramatisch für uns alle sein und
es bewegt sich viel aber leider immer
noch nicht genug
das pariser abkommen sieht in erster
linie die reduzierung unserer
treibhausgas emissionen vor
doch was wenn wir den ausstoß von
treibhausgasen nicht schnell genug
zurück fahren können was wenn wir
weiterhin benzin diesel und kohle in
riesigen mengen verbrennen
gibt es nicht auch irgendeinen anderen
weg
mering hört man in diesem zusammenhang
seit einigen jahren immer wieder
sozusagen als retter in der not
verspricht es die erderwärmung durch
gezielte eingriffe ins klima zu stoppen
und das im besten fall ohne unseren
ausstoß an co2 durch aufwändige
einschränkungen verringern zu müssen
das klingt fast zu gut um wahr zu sein
und tatsächlich wird die engineering
unter experten immer wieder sehr
kritisch betrachtet
warum das so ist und ob die engineering
wirklich eine alternative sein kann
damit beschäftigen wir uns heute im
video falls es noch nicht getan habt
abonniert gerne den kanal damit ihr kein
neues video verpasst den wir laden jede
woche ein neues hoch
[Musik]
ein paar hunderttausend weiter guck mal
eben wie auch das überall existenzen
gefährdet sind durch die klimakrise die
hier gemacht wird
dieses video wird unterstützt von blink
ist wir achten bei unserem sponsoring es
tatsächlich immer darauf dass wir nur
produkte bewerben die wir auch selber
empfehlen würden und fasst euch sagen
blinkt ist benutze ich selber schon seit
über drei jahren und ich freue mich sehr
nun endlich auch hier auf einem kanal
davon erzählen zu können
blinken ist bricht quasi lange bücher
auf das wesentliche herunter damit man
sie in nur circa 15 minuten lesen kann
oder wenn ihr so wie ich seit und die
gerne hörbücher zum einschlafen hört
dann könnt ihr euch diese 15-minütigen
blinkx auch einfach anhören
es gibt über 3000 sachbüchern angebot
und so ratgeber klassiker bestseller und
das aus über 25 kategorien wie
wissenschaft produktivität und
psychologie und jeden monat kommen ca 40
15 minütige blinkx hinzu und wenn ihr
doch mal tief in ein buch einsteigen
wollt dann findet ihr inzwischen auch
ganze hörbücher auf blinkt ist im moment
gibt es eine ziemlich coole aktion mit
der ihr 20 prozent auf ein jahres abo
blinkt ist premium sparen könnt dafür
müsst ihr nur auf linke.de doktor watson
gehen und ein abo abschließen und wenn
ihr euch jetzt noch nicht ganz sicher
sein ob das ganze so euer ding ist dann
könnt ihr das komplette angebot auch
erst mal sieben tage lang kostenlos
testen ohne irgendwelche bedingungen
danke an blinkt ist für die vielen
coolen dinge die ich durch den letzten
jahren gelernt habe und damit zurück zum
video jane schniering oder auch climate
engineering beschreibt die bewusste
beeinflussung des klimas unserer erde
mit hilfe von menschlichen eingriffen
sollen natürliche kreisläufe zu unseren
gunsten manipuliert werden
das ganze soll neben der erwärmung der
erde auch die versauerung der meere
stoppen
dabei teilt sich die engineering group
in zwei bereiche auf solar die asian
management kurz esm ist die
kontrollierte reduzierung von
sonneneinstrahlung auf die erde und
unter kabel roxette rubel also cdu
versteht man maßnahmen die co2 aus der
atmosphäre entnehmen sollen
das klingt doch beides
nach einer guten idee mit sm also dem
strahlungs management will man die menge
der sonnenstrahlung auf die erde
kontrollieren
denn je nachdem wie viel strahlung ins
erreicht erhitzt sich der boden mehr
oder weniger beim scm gibt es
verschiedene ansätze durch die
sonnenstrahlen reflektiert werden sollen
einer dieser ansätze ist und das ist
kein scherz große spiegel ins weltall zu
bringen und damit das licht der sonne
einfach wieder ins all zurück zu
reflektieren
das klingt vielleicht etwas absurd aber
warum dennoch nicht damit wäre auf jeden
fall sichergestellt dass die
sonnenstrahlen die er hatte gar nicht
erst erreichen
insgesamt wird diese idee aber am ende
wahrscheinlich zu teuer und auch zu
umständlich sein um wirklich realität zu
werden
ein etwas realistischere ansatz wäre es
nicht einzelne große sondern unzählige
kleine spiegel zu benutzen
die rede ist hier von partikeln genauer
gesagt schwefeloxiden die in die
stratosphäre gesprüht werden sollen
dort könnten sie dann einen großteil der
sonnenstrahlen zurück ins all
reflektieren
bisher wurde diese methode aufgrund
rechtliche einschränkungen zwar noch
nicht umfangreich getestet wo zu führen
könnte weiß man allerdings trotzdem die
idee ist nämlich inspiriert von
vulkanausbrüchen bei denen häufig viele
tonnen schwefeldioxid ausgestoßen werden
die partikel halten sich dann meistens
für einige monate oder sogar bis zu zwei
jahre in der atmosphäre und reflektieren
das sonnenlicht das ergebnis es wird
kälter aber auch für diese idee etwas
näher an der realität ist steht bisher
noch nicht fest wie teuer und aufwendig
sie wirklich wäre um global wirken zu
können
eine weitere möglichkeit wäre der
einsatz von sogenannten aerosolen auch
das sind kleine partikel an denen sich
wiederum verdunstet das wasser sammelt
und wieder kondensiert
auf diese weise entstehen künstliche
wolken die das sonnenlicht blockieren
und so ebenfalls die erde abkühlen
sollen darüber hinaus gibt es natürlich
noch viele andere möglichkeiten um
reflexion flächen zu erzeugen wie zum
beispiel durch die aufhellung von
dächern oder von ganzen wüsten flächen
okay das klingt ja erst mal alles über
spannend ist aber am ende des tages ein
weiterer menschliche eingriff in die
natur die erderwärmung ist ja an sich
nur ein symptom und nicht die ursache
aber dazu später noch mal mehr an
unseren co2 aus halt ändern die slm
methoden also erstmal nichts aber dafür
haben wir immer noch zehn jahre carbon
dioxide removal auch hier gibt es
verschiedene methoden die
unterschiedliche ansätze verfolgen
in jedem fall soll co2 aus dem
natürlichen kreislauf entnommen und
gespeichert werden
möglichkeiten co2 aus der atmosphäre zu
filtern wären zum beispiel die
aufforstung von wäldern oder das
gezielte anbauen von algen im meer durch
ozeandüngung wiederaufforstung ist
generell schon mal eine super sache dass
jedes jahr eine riesige fläche wald
unter anderem für die landwirtschaft
abgeholzt wird hat einen enormen
einfluss auf den klimawandel
denn pflanzen nehmen während der
photosynthese co2 auf und speichern ist
das bedeutet je größer die waldfläche
auf der erde ist desto mehr co2 wird
natürlich gebunden seien
problematisch wird es dann wenn pflanzen
verbrannt oder abgeholzt werden und aus
ihnen energie gewonnen werden soll
beim verbrennen von biomasse wird das
ganze co2 nämlich wieder freigesetzt
der ansatz des eba ist das freigesetzte
co2 aufzufangen bevor es wieder in die
atmosphäre gelangt durch chemische
prozesse soll dann die photosynthese
simuliert das co2 wieder gebunden und
dann irgendwo unterirdisch oder in den
tiefen der ozeane gespeichert werden
der ganze ablauf von pflanzen der bäume
über das abholzen bis hin zum speichern
das co2 wird übrigens beide energy mit
carbon capture and storage genannt
alternativ dazu wird auch über die
möglichkeiten von sogenannten direct er
kesha methoden nachgedacht diese sollen
co2 einfach aus der luft filtern und
dann im besten fall sogar weiter
verwenden wie man aus co2 zb kraftstoffe
sogenannte e fuels herstellen kann
darüber habe ich übrigens in diesem
video hier schon mal gesprochen und war
sogar bei der weltweit ersten
integrierten anlage in karlsruhe das ein
super interessantes und auch
nachhaltiges thema also schaut dann
gerne mal rein
das waren jetzt bei weitem noch nicht
alle ansätze mit denen solar radiation
management und carpenter york sowie
betrieben werden könnten
das umweltbundesamt hat dazu aber schon
2011 einen sehr ausführlichen bericht
herausgegeben der die verschiedenen
ideen beschreibt und auch bewertet wenn
sich das mal anschauen will der findet
passend zu dieser nummer hier unten in
der video beschreibung die quelle
insgesamt erhofft man sich durch ist
ideal und srm die erwärmung der erde zu
verlangsamen und im besten fall sogar
auf zu halten um nicht vom
gesellschaftlichen wandel hin zu
nachhaltigkeit und umweltschutz abhängig
zu sein will man das klima einfach
selbst steuern und die idee ist nicht
mal wirklich neu auch der wunsch das
wetter zu kontrollieren beschäftigt uns
menschen schon länger zum beispiel gibt
es schon seit 1977 die enviromental
modification convention
dort wird festgehalten dass eingriffe in
natürliche kreisläufe unserer erde zur
kriegsführung verboten sind
aber auch wirtschaftlich ist man eine
kontrolle des wetters interessiert seit
1975 starten zum beispiel regelmäßig die
rosenheimer hagelt lieder umfelder am
nördlichen alpenrand vor hagel unwetter
zu schützen
das funktioniert indem eine silberjodid
aceton lösung in einer am flugzeug
angebrachten brennkammer entzündet wird
durch die flamme entsteht rauch der sehr
viele kleine kondensationskeime enthält
an denen bilden sich schnell kleinere
hagelkörner die auf dem weg zum boden
dann zu regeln schmelzen und bei den
olympischen spielen 2008 in peking
verhinderte das staatliche amt für
wetterbeeinflussung china hat darf ein
amt quasi eine schönwetter amt das die
eröffnungsfeier durch ein unwetter
gestört wurde
indem man ganz 1104 raketen in eine
nahende gewitterfront schoss die regnete
sich dann einfach ab bevor sie das
stadion erreichen konnte solche wetter
beeinflussen sind natürlich noch kein
genie ring gehen aber in eine ähnliche
richtung ging sollten dabei helfen
menschen und tiere vor der erderwärmung
zu schützen sowie china die
stadionbesucher vor regen geschützt hat
wer sollte also da etwas dagegen haben
fragen wir das doch mal die einwohner
von peking die im november 2009 am
flughafen standen in der bahn saßen oder
mit dem auto unterwegs waren
innerhalb von kürzester zeit fielen dort
nämlich ohne vorwarnung satte 16
millionen tonnen schnee vom himmel
die folge waren autounfälle und
stromausfälle zudem saßen viele chinesen
frierend in ihren wohnungen weil die
heizungen noch nicht eingeschaltet war
und warum das ganze
weil das wetter änderungs abend
eigentlich durch künstlichen regen die
anhaltende dürre in der provinz beenden
wollte dabei jedoch nicht mit dem
einfluss der natur gerechnet hat eine
kaltfront hatte den regen nämlich
kurzerhand in schnee verwandelt und die
stadt ins chaos gestürzt
und das ist eines der größten probleme
dass kritiker mit geo engineering haben
die schwer bis unmöglich vorherzusagen
den folgen
in der studie des umweltbundesamtes von
2011 wurden viele der geo engineering
methoden untersucht und eingeordnet
das fazit der wissenschaftler war damals
dass die tatsächlichen auswirkungen von
jay spearing auf unsere erde nur schwer
abschätzbar seien
im schlimmsten fall könnten die
negativen auswirkungen auf unsere erde
sogar noch verstärkt werden
die künstliche speicherung von co2 in
den weltmeeren könnte zb genau das
gegenteil von dem tun was eigentlich das
ziel ist und zu einem anstieg der
versorgung führen sollte sich das co2
dort unkontrolliert lösen bei der
großflächigen aufforstung der wälder
besteht die gefahr dass durch den
einsatz hocheffizienter monokulturen die
artenvielfalt enorm zurückgeht
darüber hinaus wird die aufforstung von
wäldern alleine auch nicht die lösung
sein
eine studie des potsdam instituts für
klimafolgenforschung hat herausgefunden
dass wir um die ziele des pariser
klimaabkommens einhalten zu können
ein viertel der weltweiten
landwirtschaftlichen fläche für neue
wälder nutzen müssten zusätzlich zur
reduzierung des co2 ausstoßes
doch so unvorhersehbar die folgen auch
sein können verdammen sollte man sie
engineering auf der anderen seite auch
nicht denn laut einer 2016
veröffentlichten studie des stockholm
resilience centers kommen wir um den
einsatz sogenannter negativ im mission
technologies nicht herum
zumindest nicht wenn wir die
klimaerwärmung auf zwei grad im
vergleich zur vorindustriellen zeit
beschränken wollen
wir scheinen also in einer zeit zu
sitzen die warnungen der klimaforscher
sind klar wenn wir es nicht schaffen die
erwärmung unserer erde zu stoppen oder
zumindest einzudämmen
kann das schwerwiegende folgen für uns
alle haben durch die un schniering
könnte die erderwärmung verringert
werden die gefahren lassen sich aber
anscheinend noch schwer einschätzen
da stellt sich natürlich die frage warum
investieren wir nicht in die erforschung
der folgen von geoengineering immerhin
müssen wir irgendetwas tun oder
nun sollten wir schaffen durch zum
beispiel solar radiation management das
klima der erde abzukühlen ohne unsere
co2 emissionen zu reduzieren wurde zwar
weniger wärme in form von strahlung auf
die erde gelangen
es könnte aber auch weniger wärme von
der erde abstrahlen weil wir noch so
viel co2 in der atmosphäre haben so
würde sich der effekt immer weiter
ausgleichen und wir müssen immer weiter
immer mehr strahlung abblocken
auch die möglichkeiten der co2
speicherung wären da zumindest in den
ersten jahren nur bedingt hilfreich
es wird leider ziemlich lange dauern bis
wirklich genug co2 aus der atmosphäre
entnommen wurde
damit die methode spürbare änderungen
zeigt wir würden in diesem szenario für
die nächsten hundert bis tausend jahre
nur versuchen das schlimmste zu
verhindern
wirklich rosige aussichten sind das
nicht kann jamie ring also wirklich
einen plan b sein forscher kritisieren
dass sich staaten darauf verlassen
könnten im zweifelsfall hat nachträglich
durch die engineering das ruder
herumzureißen
oder noch schlimmer gar nicht erst den
aufwand betreiben ihre emissionen
einzusparen und sich direkt auf diese
bequemere alternative verlassen
das wird aber leider nicht funktionieren
denn damit würden wir die symptome
bekämpfen anstatt das problem an der
wurzel zu packen und das sind nun mal
unsere emissionen
abgesehen davon ergeben sich auch
rechtliche fragen länder die geo
engineering einsetzen würden direkten
einfluss auf das globale klima nehmen
die möglichkeiten dazu ständen nur den
reichen ländern zur verfügung
entwicklungsländer könnten zwar
theoretisch auch vom einsatz profitieren
wären aber im schlimmsten fall wenn
irgendetwas schiefgeht auch die ersten
leidtragenden
auch das umweltbundesamt hat rechtliche
bedenken geäußert und setzt für den
sinnvollen einsatz von geoengineering
voraus dass der mensch alle ökologischen
prozesse versteht und kontrollieren kann
und dass dem noch lange nicht so ist
sollten nicht nur die einwohner von
peking erkannt haben
am ende bleiben die fragen was können
wir tun und was sollten wir tun es wird
sehr wahrscheinlich keine entweder oder
entscheidung zwischen
emissionseinsparungen
zentraler punkt des klimaschutzes muss
weiterhin die reduzierung der
treibhausgase seien und um dann eine
positive kehrtwende einleiten zu können
wäre zum beispiel ein bedachter einsatz
von karben wie moodle maßnahmen zur co2
bindung denkbar vielleicht sogar
unvermeidlich
das funktioniert aber nicht ohne dass
die technologien weiter erforscht werden
wichtig ist dass wir die probleme jetzt
angehen und deren ursache bekämpfen wir
können uns leider nicht auf bequemen
alternativen verlassen wir müssen etwas
ändern und zwar nachhaltig es bringt
nichts die probleme einfach in die
zukunft zu schieben denn wozu das führt
sehen wir im moment dazu übrigens könnt
ihr gerne mal in die video beschreibung
gucken haben wir alle quellen zu diesem
video hier verlinkt aber jetzt würde
mich mal eure meinung interessieren
glaubt ihr dass wir von einem einsatz
von geoengineering absehen können und
was halten die überhaupt von den
verschiedenen methoden vielleicht seht
ihr das ganze ja sogar anders und sagt
der meinung dass geo engineering alle
unsere probleme lösen kann
lasst uns gerne darüber sachlich in den
kommentaren diskutieren und wenn ihr uns
unterstützen wollt dann unterstützen sie
gerne auch paige hören da könnt ihr zum
beispiel manche videos früher gucken und
darüber entscheiden welche videos als
nächstes machen die immer vielen dank
fürs zuschauer und bleibt neugierig
bringen beschreibt und bewertet mehr
dazu mal den bericht reinschauen will
der schaut am besten in dieser quelle
hier nach dieser quelle